the House Intelligence Committee is
expected to vote today to release a
democratic response to a Declassified
memo on the Russian investigation this
morning for GOP members of the House
committee are rejecting president
Trump's view of that memo produced by
the committee's Republican chairman the
president tweeted quote this memo
totally vindicates Trump Margaret
Brennan is at the White House with the
latest on the story Margaret good
morning to you good morning well four
days from now government funding may run
out but most much of the focus here in
Washington is on that Republican memo
which accuses the FBI of political bias
when it had obtained a warrant from a
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Court
or FISA Court there is a little bit of
sweet revenge in it for me and certainly
probably the family Donald Trump jr.
echoed his father's claim that the
Republican authored memo discredits the
Russia investigation but one of the
memos key authors South Carolina
congressman trey Gowdy told Face the
Nation that it does not let the
president off the hook I actually don't
think it has any impact on the Russia
probe for this reason the memo has no
impact on the Russia probe no no not to
me it doesn't and I was pretty
integrally involved in the drafting of
it the four page memo accuses the FBI
and Justice Department of abusing
surveillance powers by obtaining a
warrant to spy on Trump campaign aide
Carter page using an unverified dossier
financed by Democrats as key evidence
but Gowdy says there are a number of
concerning incidents that still need to
be investigated including Donald Trump
Jr's meeting at Trump Tower with Russian
nationals the dossier has nothing to do
with the meeting at Trump Tower the
dossier has nothing to do with an email
sent by Cambridge analytical the dossier
really has nothing to do with George
papadopolis his meeting in Great Britain
it also doesn't have anything to do with
obstruction of justice so there's going
to be a Russia probe even without a
dossier the surveillance on page was
authorized four times and was approved
by several high-ranking officials at the
FBI and Department of Justice including
the current Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosen Stein on Friday the president was
asked if he still had confidence in him
you figured that one out
while the memo largely faux
son Carter page it also revealed that
the FBI investigation was triggered in
July 2016 based on information about
another Trump foreign policy aide named
George papadopolis who has since pled
guilty to line two FBI agents Norah all
right Margaret thank you so much